[Music]
called back to be put on display russian
soldiers rehearsed for victory day the
may 9th anniversary marks russia's
triumph over nazi germany in the second
world war
the day is celebrated across europe
but this year it carries new
significance moscow will look to
highlight victories in ukraine despite
achieving very little
leaving ukraine's president to issue a
warning to obey curfews and air raid
sirens with fear russia could increase
its attacks
those worries a reality on saturday with
strikes in the southern port city of
odessa and across the east
the ground started crumbling the roof
was shaking says this donetsk resident
this is rebel-controlled territory
the enemy is carrying out artillery
shelling and air assaults to strike
positions of our troops says a
spokesperson for ukraine's armed forces
on friday u.s president joe biden
committed to another 150 million dollars
in aid a move rattling russia's nerves
leading to more veiled threats against
the west
and while ukraine's president is eager
for a diplomatic end he says russia
doesn't appear to be willing to engage
but for so many the end came weeks ago
it's a shame to look at this i lived
here for 40 years
72 year old zenita baranchuk lost
everything on march 24th she now lives
in this trailer beside the remains of
her home
i never thought the russian brothers
would attack us and do something like
this with my ukraine she says
meanwhile after a phone call on friday
to underscore a joint commitment in
holding russia accountable both
president biden and prime minister
justin trudeau will join their g7
counterparts for a video conference on
sunday with the invitation extended to
ukraine's president where sanctions are
expected to be on the agenda